le premier gouvernement d'elisabeth
bornes aura duré six semaines et demain
le remaniement devrait être annoncé avec
dans l'après midi un conseil des
ministres ce qui demain aujourd'hui
entreront au gouvernement doivent
pouvoir partager la feuille de route qui
a été choisie par les français parce que
parfois à entendre certains commentaires
j'ai l'impression que présente la
réplique n'a pas été réélu je pense
qu'il serait problématique qu'elle donne
pas la mission que le vote de confiance
mais nous nous chargerons au long de la
nuit de déposer une motion de censure la
halle plusieurs sources au sein de rfi
j'ai entendu plusieurs fois des femmes
parler du comportement qu'il aurait avec
les femmes ce sont des choses qui
reviennent de manière récurrente depuis
plusieurs années madame diallo a le soir
même rendu publique une rumeur qui
courait sur les réseaux sociaux depuis
des années il ne s'était jamais exprimé
sur des médias et qui à partir de man de
là c'était pas très agréable pour moi
mais reste est circoncis pascal a rendu
une rumeur basée et je vais y venir sur
aucun fait aucun témoignage je ne me
permettrais pas de m'exprimer sur des
rumeurs je pense que sur la base de
rumeurs et je ne vois pas quelle
décision on pourrait prendre je n'ai
jamais eu de ma vie et c'est quelque
chose que j'abhorre quelque chose qui
pourrait sa part sa parenté un acquis
qui est un comportement que ce soit
harcèlement ne faut pas que la machine
s'emballe autour de rumeurs à nouveau
j'invite chaque victime a porté plainte
nous avons fait tout pour que le recueil
de cette plainte soit le mieux fait
possible tout juste pose comme le monde
où tout peut avoir des gens qui
l'instrumentalisent ont pris pour des
raisons politiques ça arrive on n'est
pas dans un monde de bisounours et mois
par an ils subissent à ce que les
magistrats aient subi ça avant
législatif si on commence désormais à
rentrer dans des campagnes de
dénonciation ou immédiatement les
personnes doivent démissionner la
politique française et la vie politique
en général va devenir immédiatement une
succession de dénonciation imaginaire ou
réel
mais de bout en bout illustre les
tensions qui fracturent la société leur
vg une collision volontaire entre une
voiture et ce pick-up camouflage qui
perd le contrôle sort de la route et se
retrouve sur le toit c'est pour ça que
la france insoumis et autant en
difficulté c'est qu'ils n'ont pas
toujours la même ligne c'est dire que
c'est le premier à attaquer sur des
rumeurs leurs opposants politiques sur
ces mêmes sujets par contre d'exceller
l'heure plutôt protégé et d'irm
attendait cet incident c'est très grave
des hacker sur le hummer tous sont des
militants d'extrême droite anti cela
quelques minutes plus tôt il s'était
rendu à morton route dans la banlieue
d'oslo où vit une importante communauté
musulmane pour mettre le feu à un
courant dans ce cas une indignations à
géométrie verbe de la part de la gauche
notamment dans ça concerne quelqu'un de
son son camp qui encore une fois n'a pas
été condamnée y a pas d' enquête mais ne
voit aucun problème à dire qu'il doit
rester rester en poste le cas de damien
abad est en suspens le ministre des
solidarités et fragilisé par une enquête
préliminaire pour tentative de viol je
commence la bad devrait démissionner ça
serait mieux pour lui ça serait mieux
pour les plaignantes ça serait mieux
pour la justice ça serait mieux au sein
de l'assemblée nationale
damien abad lui fait l'objet d'une
pelote maintenant mais en plus de
témoignages à visage découvert
répéter et donc et qu'ils aient mois il
d'une plainte doit partir mais d'une
plainte et donc pour moi je ne mets pas
même niveau une femme saisit alors le
livre encore fumants invectives
elle s'engouffre ensuite dans ce
véhicule gris et prend en chasse la
recette aurait une course-poursuite
débute sur l'autoroute la voiture
percute le pick-up une première fois le
phénomène inexpliqué des piqûres à
garorock à marmande
une vingtaine de personnes ont signalé
avoir été piquées et l'ont fait
constater par les forces de l'ordre hier
la conductrice du véhicule a été
interpellé elle est poursuivie pour
collision intentionnel et tentatives de
violences aggravées